salut c'est Romain demi l'idée de
culture générale j'ai deux petites
choses importantes à vous dire avant que
la vidéo ne commence première chose ne
regardez pas la vidéo comme ça avec du
pop-corn
[Musique]
si vous voulez retenir ce que vous allez
apprendre dans cette vidéo vous devez
prendre des notes les études sur la
mémorisation ne laissent aucune place au
doute ne pas prendre de notes égal
oublier donc faites-moi plaisir ouvrez
une application comme Google Docs Wever
not et notez ce qui est essentiel pour
vous au fur et à mesure seconde chose
que je dois vous dire la vidéo vous
allez regarder est extraite de ma
formation de culture générale qui
s'appelle culture Express c'est une
formation qui permet d'acquérir
rapidement une bonne culture générale
sans se prendre la tête sans avoir à
lire ni à réfléchir elle couvre tous les
domaines de la culture générale elle
permet de maîtriser les connaissances
essentielles sur l'histoire de
l'humanité sur l'histoire de France en
économie en sciences politiques en
psychologie en sciences en littérature
en art en religion et enfin en
philosophie ah oui c'est important la
philo si ça vous intéresse je désire un
coup d’œil soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant en haut à droite
de la vidéo soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description de cette
vidéo voilà voilà je vous ai dit ce que
je voulais vous dire maintenant je vous
laisse regarder la vidéo concentrez-vous
préparez-vous à prendre des notes et
puis n'hésitez pas à m'écrire dans les
commentaires et moi je vous dis à la
prochaine
[Musique]
la psychanalyse
Freud n'était pas un génie de la science
mais de la propagande écrit Hans eiseng
dans déclin et chute de l'Empire fredien
lors de ma dernière année d'études en
école de commerce en 2011 j'ai choisi en
option un cours d'introduction à la
psychanalyse je me souviens encore de la
toute première séance les diapositives
de la prof des filets et lorsque la
diapositive consacrée à la définition de
la psychanalyse est apparue j'étiquet il
était écrit la psychanalyse est une
science blablabla je n'ai pas pu
m'empêcher de lever la main pour
demander à la prof si elle était bien
certaine qu'on pouvait définir la
psychanalyse comme une science et elle
l'a mal pris c'était pile l’époque de la
sortie du pamphlet de Michel Onfray sur
Freud livre qui faisait grand bruit et
qui mettait à mal la crédibilité de la
psychanalyse dans l'opinion publique la
prof a répondu à ma question comme les
psychanalystes ont réagi au livre de
Michel Onfray la remise en cause de la
psychanalyse est une attaque politique
c'est une persécution orchestrée par des
mouvements xénophobes voire antisémites
de telles réactions épidermique sont
révélatrices de la fragilité des idées
psychanalytiques parce qu'une pensée
solide n'a pas besoin de quitter le
terrain de l'argumentation pour se
défendre pour autant il ne faut pas en
conclure que tout est à jeté certaines
conceptions de la psychanalyse sont
certes des idées fausses qui ne
correspondent pas à la réalité de
l'esprit humain mais d'autres
conceptions dont une bonne part ont été
puisés dans l'histoire de la pensée mais
d'autres conceptions semblent juste et
sont utiles pour comprendre le monde de
surcroît et c'est là à mon avis la
principale raison du succès de la
psychanalyse elle est séduisante en
effet elle est une théorie déterministe
de l'esprit l'esprit une terre inconnue
dont cette théorie postule qu'elle
obéite à un enchaînement nécessaire de
cause et d'effet et en faisant la part
belle dans les déterminismes de l'esprit
au secret et à la sexualité elle attire
naturellement l'attention de l'opinion
publique la psychanalyse est de loin la
plus influente des écoles de pensée
psychologique du 20e siècle
dans cette leçon je vais répondre aux
questions suivantes qu'est-ce que la
psychanalyse que retenir de Freud
quelles sont les idées essentielles de
Freud quels sont les développements
majeurs de la psychanalyse et enfin
quels sont les limites de la
psychanalyse
est-ce que la psychanalyse je vais tout
d'abord élucider le sens du terme
psychanalyse je définirai ensuite plus
précisément ce qu'on appelle la
psychanalyse enfin je vous expliquerai
comment on peut caractériser le
praticien de la psychanalyse le
psychanalyste
que signifie le mot psychanalyse Freud
le fondateur de la psychanalyse emploie
ce nouveau terme pour la première fois
en 1896 pour désigner la méthode
d'analyse psychologique de Joseph
broyeur
josefbruer un médecin autrichien qui est
son ami proche et avec lequel il
travaillait ils écriront d'un livre sur
l'hystérie ensemble la méthode de
broyeur qui inspirera fortement Freud
consiste à retrouver des émotions
bloquées provoquées par des événements
oubliés et à faire parler le patient
afin de lever le blocage émotionnel
Freud et ses collègues considéreront
même jusqu’à la Première Guerre mondiale
que c'est broyeur qui a inventé la
psychanalyse
sur le plan de la langue le terme
psychanalyse est formé par la jonction
de psycho le mot grec qui signifie
l'esprit et du mot français analyse
issus du grec anal huane anal qui
signifie défaire une trame le terme
analyse signifie dans l'absolu l'étude
d'un ensemble on le décomposant en ses
éléments constitutifs mais depuis le 18e
siècle il désigne l'examen psychologique
de comportement pour l'anecdote au début
Freud qui maîtrise le français et qui
travaille en partie dans cette langue au
début freud parle de psychoanalyse
psychoalyse parce qu'il se trompe sur
les règles de formation des mots
français à partir du grec
ainsi dans l'absolu le terme
psychanalyse désignerait l'étude de
l'esprit humain en le décomposant en ces
éléments constitutifs il y a bien cela
dans la psychanalyse au sens strict mais
elle est quelque chose de bien plus
précis
dans le détail on peut distinguer trois
usages du terme psychanalyse tout
d'abord l'usage du grand public qui
tente à appeler psychanalyse toute
pratique d'analyse psychologique ou
toute psychothérapie il y a ensuite
l'usage intellectuel qui appelle
psychanalyse toute conception selon
laquelle il existe une partie cachée
dont l'esprit humain et selon laquelle
il faut mettre à jour cette partie
cachée afin de guérir les troubles
psychologiques troisième et dernier
usage l'usage des partisans de Freud
pour lesquels le terme psychanalyse
désigne exclusivement la théorie et la
pratique fondée sur les textes freudiens
comment définir la psychanalyse le terme
psychanalyse ne suffit donc pas à
comprendre ce qu'elle est pour cela il
faut connaître sa doctrine et son
histoire pour faire simple la
psychanalyse est une école psychologique
qui prétend guérir des troubles
psychiques et ou physique en rendant
consciente des pensées dont l'ignorance
est à l'origine des troubles c'est donc
simplement une nouvelle version de la
vieille idée du secret pathogène que
j'ai évoqué dans des leçons précédentes
selon laquelle l'homme se rend malade en
se cachant certaines choses à lui-même
ou en se mentant à lui-même mais la
psychanalyse enrichit l'histoire de la
psychologie en construisant autour de la
vieille idée du secret pathogène une
doctrine ainsi qu'une méthode
thérapeutique mais quelle est la
définition officielle de la psychanalyse
la définition classique pose trois
éléments constitutifs premier élément la
psychanalyse est un procédé
d'investigation de processus psychiques
lesquels demeurent inaccessibles sans se
procéder deuxième élément constitutif
l'investigation nourrit ensuite une
autre dimension constitutive de la
psychanalyse elle est aussi une méthode
de traitement des troubles névrotiques
c'est-à-dire des troubles nerveux sans
base organique des solables
et enfin troisième et dernier élément
constitutif la psychanalyse est une
série de conceptions psychologiques
acquise grâce à l’investigation et au
traitement et les psychanalystes
considèrent que ce nouveau savoir
constitue progressivement une nouvelle
discipline scientifique je reviendrai
sur la question de savoir si la
psychanalyse est bien une science
la psychanalyse commença comme une
thérapie toutefois ce n'est pas comme
thérapie que je voulais la recommander à
votre intérêt mais en raison de sa
teneur en vérité a dit Freud dans ses
nouvelles conférences de 1933
après la domination de Freud n'a pas
empêché la psychanalyse de se diviser en
diverses écoles qui proposent diverses
définitions après la Première Guerre
mondiale ces disciples se plaignaient du
fait que le terme psychanalyse soit
utiliser à tort et à travers certains
reprocheront notamment aux thérapeutes
américains de s'appeler psychanalyste
alors que leur pratique n'a plus rien à
voir avec la psychanalyse
qu'est-ce qu'un psychanalyste le
psychanalyste et le thérapeute qui suit
la méthode psychanalytique Freud appelé
ses clients malades patients ou névrosés
les psychanalystes contemporains les
appellent désormais analysés voire
analysant pour suggérer que c'est le
client qui fait lui-même le travail et
que le psychanalyste n'est qu'un
médiateur
si psychiatre et psychologues sont des
titres légaux liés à un diplôme
universitaire ce n'est pas le cas du
titre de psychanalyste il n'est pas
nécessaire de suivre une formation pour
son prévaloir aucun pays au monde n'a
posé une telle condition à ma
connaissance ainsi n'importe qui a le
droit de faire de l'analyse
psychologique et de se présenter comme
analyste ou psychanalyste de la même
manière que n’importe qui peut se dire
philosophe historien comportementaliste
coach graphologue ou astrologue rien
n'empêche des psychanalystes autodidacte
ou autoproclamés de se définir comme des
professionnels alors qu'ils n'ont suivi
aucun cursus psychologique ou
psychiatrique ni même psychanalytique
c'est pour cette raison que Freud a
favorisé la création de l'Association
psychanalytique internationale est un
national psycho analytical association
IPA en anglais en l'année 1910
en 1925 cette association a posé les
deux règles que doivent suivre les
psychanalystes qui souhaitent qu'elle
les reconnaissent première règle il faut
étudier les écrits du fondateur et puis
second règle il faut faire ce qu'on
appelle une analyse didactique
c'est-à-dire se faire psychanalyser par
un confrère et cela auprès d'un analyste
sorti d'une école agréée par
l'association
toutefois Freud lui-même relativisera
l'importance des règles afin de
favoriser la diffusion de sa nouvelle
discipline le titre de psychanalyste
sera encore plus facile à obtenir
lorsque Jacques Lacan créera sa propre
société de psychanalyse l'École
freudienne de Paris en 1964 les deux
règles sautent n'importe qui peut
s'inscrire
le psychanalyste ne s'autorise que de
lui-même disait Jacques Lacan
que retenir de freudes je vais tout
d'abord vous résumer le parcours de
Freud Sigmund de son prénom je vous
expliquerai ensuite comment il a fondé
la psychanalyse puis je vous présenterai
les cas les plus connus parmi ceux qui
lui ont permis d'élaborer la doctrine
psychanalytique enfin je vous parlerai
de la postérité de Freud dans les
sociétés occidentales
qui est Freud Sigmund Freud est un
médecin plus précisément en neurologue
autrichien qui a vécu dans la seconde
moitié du XIXe siècle et dans la
première moitié du 20e il est né en 1856
dans une famille juive de l'Empire
d'Autriche dont le territoire était plus
vaste que l’autriche actuelle dès
l'enfance il fait preuve d'intelligence
et d'une grande puissance de travail
c'est pourquoi il est le préféré de ses
parents il lui répète qu'il est
exceptionnel et il lui réserve un
traitement de faveur il a sa propre
pièce pour étudier il passe un temps fou
dans les livres ses parents l'autorise
même à manger seul dans son bureau afin
qu'il gagne du temps de lecture et cela
explique son exceptionnelle culture
littéraire il a bien sûr d'excellents
résultats scolaires à l'adolescence à
l'heure de choisir sa voie
professionnelle il est tenté d'imiter
son meilleur ami de l'époque qui choisit
le droit pour s'investir en politique
cependant l'admiration de Freud pour
Darwin le décide à s'inscrire en
médecine il lit pas mal de philosophie
pendant ces années à la fac de médecine
d'où la dimension philosophique de la
psychanalyse il envisage même à un
moment de faire un doctorat mais ces
études de médecine sont trop prenantes
il rencontre Martha Bernays B e R n a Ys
sa future femme à 25 ans le mariage et
sa consommation sont repoussés pendant 4
ans ce qui fait souffrir Freud en effet
il manque d'argent et il veut disposer
de son propre cabinet de consultation
avant de fonder un foyer
comment Freud fond de t-il la
psychanalyse
je me sens en droit d'affirmer que
personne ne peut savoir mieux que moi ce
qu'est la psychanalyse écrit Sigmund
Freud dans sa contribution à l'histoire
du mouvement
contrairement à ce que l'escroît Freud
et ses plus proches soutiens la
psychanalyse ne sort pas exniilo de son
seul génie créatif elle est tout d'abord
le fruit d'un contexte c'est une
réaction au paradigme psychologique de
la fin du 19e siècle on considère à
l'époque que tout problème de l'esprit
humain à sa source dans le corps dans le
fonctionnement des nerfs et on
approfondit donc l'étude des organes
afin de corriger les anomalies de l'âme
mais comme on l'a vu dans la deuxième
leçon de ce module les français eux
voient également les choses dans l'autre
sens il s'intéresse aux causes
psychiques des troubles notamment par le
biais de l'hypnose après ce que 30 ans
Freud de se rend grâce à une bourse à
Paris pour se former auprès de
Jean-Martin Charcot qui l’impressionne
par son éloquence et son charisme il
revient à Vienne avec une nouvelle
perspective sur l'esprit ainsi qu'une
nouvelle méthode l'hypnose qui ne
plaisent pas beaucoup à ses collègues
les deux autres influences décisives
pour la fondation de la psychanalyse
sont celles du médecin autrichien Joseph
broyeur que j'ai déjà mentionné qui se
servait déjà d'une cure par la parole et
aussi l'influence du médecin de Berlin
vilaine fils
Wilhelm
flie2s vilaine Memphis et qui fut l'ami
le plus intime de Freud dans les années
1890 et dont les idées sur la sexualité
l'influenceront fortement enfin la
fondation de la psychanalyse est
également le fruit d’influence
philosophique zinavoué et plus discrète
les plus récentes étant celle de
shopenhauer et de Nietzsche dont Freud
était fan et auquel il se comparer en se
présentant comme un destructeur
d'illusions mais à quand dater la
naissance de la psychanalyse
en 1892 alors qu'il a 36 ans Freud a
déjà rassemblé les grandes lignes de la
méthode psychanalytique l'observation
minutieuse l'association libre sans
hypnose qui consiste à laisser le
patient exprimé sans aucun contrôle les
pensées qui lui viennent les unes après
les autres et enfin dernier élément
essentiel de la méthode psychanalytique
l'interprétation par l'analyse dans les
dernières années du siècle Freud à
l'ambition d'écrire à l'ouvrage
fondateur d'une nouvelle psychologie
scientifique mais il échoue
les actes fondateurs de la psychanalyse
surviennent entre les années 1900 et
1905 c'est la publication de trois
livres phares l'interprétation du rêve
en 1900 la Psychopathologie de la vie
quotidienne en 1901 et les Trois essais
sur la théorie sexuelle en 1905 c'est la
publication de ces trois livres phares
qui diffusent les idées de Freud et qui
fait reconnaître la psychanalyse dans
l'opinion publique comme une nouvelle
thérapie psychologique deux ingrédients
ont été cruciaux dans ce succès
intellectuel première ingrédient les
sujets des trois livres le sens caché du
rêve le sens caché des actes manqués et
la sexualité ces trois sujets sont des
sujets qui fascinent les gens et puis
second ingrédient crucial Freud a un
grand talent de pédagogue il écrit dans
un style très clair avec beaucoup
d'exemples les actes publics de la
naissance de la psychanalyse surviennent
au tout début du 20e siècle mais la
légende veut que le véritable point de
départ soit l'auto-analyse menée par
Freud à partir du milieu des années 18
90 ce qui n'est par définition
vérifiables par aucune preuve enfin la
psychanalyse va encore évoluer pendant
plus de trois décennies la sexualité et
le passé individuel tout
particulièrement l'enfance vont devenir
des dimensions essentielles de la
doctrine Freud va affiner sa carte de
l'esprit et la technique psychanalytique
réviser ces théories sur les pulsions
l'anxiété et la sexualité féminine
envahir l'histoire de l'art
l'anthropologie la psychologie de la
religion et la critique culturelle
quelles sont ces cas les plus célèbres
Freud reçoit beaucoup de patients parce
qu'il a besoin d'argent il consulte 10
heures par jour disent les biographes ce
sont ces nombreuses consultations qui
ont fourni la base empirique à partir de
laquelle il a élaboré la doctrine
psychanalytique je vous résume
brièvement les 5 cas classique de la
psychanalyse le premier c'est le cas
Dana o ce cas est connu comme le tout
premier cas anao est une femme brillante
qui souffre entre autres
d'hallucinations de troubles corporels
et de troubles du langage à l'avait
d'abord été traitée par Joseph broyeur
et c'est même elle qui avait baptisé sa
méthode la cure par la parole et puis
Freud a pris le relais pour la guérir il
cherche les événements de son passé qui
pourraient être à l'origine des troubles
dans les études sur l'hystérie qu'ils
ont coécrites broyeur et Freud affirme
avoir fait disparaître tous les
symptômes les uns après les autres c'est
toutefois un mensonge l’état d'un ao ne
s'est pas amélioré elle a fait des
rechutes au point de passer la suite de
sa vie en clinique psychiatrique broy
vous souhaitez même qu'elle meurt afin
de mettre fin à ses souffrances
deuxième cas classique de la
psychanalyse le cas Dora c'est un cas
d'hystérie Dora est une jeune fille de
17-18 ans envoyée par son père parce
qu'il souhaite qu'elle accepte les
avances du mari de la femme dont lui le
père et l'amant oui je n'invente pas
Freud explique ses symptômes par un
événement du passé traumatisant l'homme
auquel elle se refuse et la embrasser
quand elle avait 13 ans et par une
masturbation excessive Dora qui a
l'esprit critique n'est pas convaincu et
interrompt le traitement après 11
semaines il faudra attendre la fin des
trentes glorieuses pour que des
analystes soient choqués du fait que
Freud se soit mis au service d'un père
manipulateur
troisième cas classique de la
psychanalyse le cas du petit Hans c'est
le cas d'enfant le plus célèbre Hans le
fils du disciple de Freud de Max graff
gr AF cet enfant a une peur intense des
chevaux à partir de l'âge de 4 ans au
point qu'il ne veut plus sortir de sa
maison son père pense immédiatement que
c'est parce qu'il a peur du grand pénis
du cheval Anser raconte qu'il a vu un
cheval chuter juste en face de leur
maison et qu'il a aussi entendu un père
dire à sa fille qu'un cheval pourrait la
mordre mais Freud et le père pense que
cela ne peut pas être aussi simple il
préfère attaquer le problème avec les
grands concepts de la psychanalyse Freud
de revoir Hans à 19 ans et c'est je cite
un magnifique jeune homme qui ne se
souvient plus de rien
quatrième cas classique de la
psychanalyse le cas de l'homme aura
c'est un cas de névrose obsessionnelle
le patient un avocat dénommé Ernst
Lanzer elle a n Z e r ce patient est
obsédé par le souvenir d'une torture
orientale qui consiste à fixer sur les
fesses impôts dans lequel il y a des
rats et il imagine que la femme qu'il
aime ainsi que son père subisse ce
supplice il a encore d'autres phobies
l'interprétation de Freud et que
l'avocat veut [ __ ] et son ami et
son père pour se venger de la menace de
castration et qu'il en veut à son père
de lui avoir interdit de se masturber
quand il avait 6 ans bien que familier
des idées de Freud le patient n'est pas
convaincu comme pour les autres cas il
est difficile d'évaluer l'efficacité du
traitement Freud affirme avoir guéri
l'avocat mais il aurait avoué à certains
de ses disciples que non enfin c'est
impossible à vérifier car l'homme aura a
été tué au début de la Première Guerre
mondiale
cinquième et dernier cas classique de la
psychanalyse le cas de l'omeloup c'est
le cas le plus controversé le patient
c'est un dieu ce panne que Jeff
Sergius pan
kejef ce patient est le fils d'un des
hommes les plus riches du sud de la
Russie il a fait deux analyses chez
Freud de 1910 à 1914 et en 1919-1920 et
il détient divers records celui des
années d'analyse environ 60 ans celui du
nombre de curs analytiques une dizaine
et enfin celui des commentaires sur son
cas son surnom vient du cauchemar par
lequel Freud de prétend avoir élucidé le
cas entre l'âge de 3 et 5 ans le patient
aurait rêvé qu'un groupe de 6 ou 7 loups
blancs serait rentrés par la fenêtre de
sa chambre et qu'il le regardait pour
Freud ce rêve signifie que l'enfant
aurait été témoin d'un coït parental
dans les deux premières années de sa vie
Freud affirme avoir résolu le cas dès la
première cure mais l'homme au loup sera
en réalité traité pour ses problèmes
psychologiques par d'autres
psychanalystes ou même à l'asile jusqu'à
sa mort à l'âge de 92 ans
avec le recul historique nous savons
aujourd'hui que ces cas classiques ne
constituent probablement pas des
réussites thérapeutiques cependant il
faut aussi reconnaître étant donné la
nouveauté de la psychanalyse à l'époque
qu'on envoyait à Freud les cas les plus
difficiles ce que tous les autres
thérapeutes avaient échoué à traiter
quelle est la postérité de Freud
je ne suis rien d'autre qu'un
conquistador par température
Freud a eu une influence exceptionnelle
à trois échelles en premier lieu son nom
est devenu synonyme de psychanalyse il
existe certes d'autres doctrines
psychanalytiques et d'autres grands
psychanalystes mais Laura de Freud
écrase toute la concurrence encore
aujourd'hui les psychanalystes font de
leur pensée et leur pratique sur
l'oeuvre de Freud qui a un peu pour eux
l'importance qu'à la Bible dans les
religions chrétiennes ils n'ont pas
renoncé au grand concept freudien alors
que les efforts de vérification par
l'expérience et par le raisonnement on
conclut que ces concepts sont pour le
moins fragiles même Jacques Lacan le
seul psychanalyste à avoir joui d'une
autorité intellectuelle comparable à
celle de Freud et encore même Lacan
interprétait les idées de Freud avec
prudence sans donner explicitement
l'impression que le fondateur de la
psychanalyse ait pu faire fausse route
en second lieu Freud a eu une grande
influence dans la sphère intellectuelle
nombreux sont après la Première Guerre
mondiale les penseurs qui se sont servis
des idées de Freud pour échafauder leurs
propres théorie Sartre qui était fasciné
par Freud a par exemple voulu fonder une
psychanalyse existentialiste la grande
influence du frodisme se manifestera
plus généralement par la domination au
XXe siècle de ce qu'on appelle la
philosophie du soupçon dont les trois
piliers sont la pensée de Marx qui a
soupçonné la société la pensée de
Nietzsche qui a soupçonné le
christianisme et enfin la pensée de
Freud qui a soupçonné la conscience
individuelle notez que cela a fait de
Freud un grand penseur et même plus
précisément un philosophe pas un grand
scientifique
cette grande influence intellectuelle se
retrouve naturellement dans la sphère
académique si vous avez étudié la
philosophie en classe de terminale en
France alors vous vous souvenez
peut-être que Freud est au programme ou
côté de Platon Aristote quant etc et
cela continue à l'université j'ai
moi-même suivi un séminaire sur Freud
dans le cadre de mon Master de
philosophie politique à la Sorbonne
autrement dit on donne affreux de la
même importance qui a dépenseur comme
Aristote ou Rousseau
en troisième lieu Freud a eu une grande
influence dans la culture occidentale
ces idées ont pénétré la sagesse
populaire dont l'homme ordinaire se sert
dans sa vie quotidienne par exemple nous
avons aujourd'hui tendance à interpréter
tout écart-verbal ou toute relation
entre un parent et son enfant sous le
prisme de la doctrine psychanalytique je
me souviens que ma mère m'avait expliqué
qu'un garçon préfère sa mère en raison
du complexe de DIP le freudisme a plus
largement changé les mentalités Stéphane
sfag estime qu'il a réduit le poids de
la morale sociale sur la psychologie
individuelle
par cette vision meilleure des lois
psychiques il a propagé dans le monde
une délicatesse et une indulgence plus
grande et crise Stefan dans Sigmund
Freud le freudisme est aussi une des
forces à l'origine de la révolution des
mœurs des années 1960 la sociologue
américaine Cherry torkel s h e r y
Turkle cette sociologue américaine
avance dans la France freudienne que la
psychanalyse c'est massifiée parce
qu'elle est légitime les conversations
sur le sexe et parce qu'elle constitue
une justification rationnelle de la
libération sexuelle
quelles sont les idées essentielles de
Freud je vais vous expliquer les quatre
idées les plus importantes de Freud
l'inconscient le refoulement le complexe
de DIP et le malaise dans la
civilisation
qu'est-ce que l'inconscient
l'inconscient se définit par opposition
à la conscience perçue comme un lieu
caché ou une force obscure à l'intérieur
de l'esprit humain il désigne tout ce
qui échappe entièrement à la conscience
malgré tous les efforts de la réflexion
pour l'atteindre par exemple si l'homme
au loup a oublié le coït parental auquel
il assistait dans les premières années
de sa vie le souvenir demeure dans son
inconscient selon Freud l’hypothèse de
l'inconscient rend nécessaire
d'abandonner l'idée de l'unité du sujet
l'esprit humain est partagé entre deux
pôles la conscience et l'inconscient
freux de voix dans ces deux pôles deux
chances spatiaux opposées et
incompatibles qui se protège l'un de
l'autre
le moi n'est pas maître dans sa propre
maison et Chris Sigmund Freud dans son
introduction à la psychanalyse il existe
diverses manifestations de l'inconscient
cela peut tout d'abord être le cas de
troubles physiques on parle de
somatisation ou de troubles psychiques à
l'image des symptômes danao
l'inconscient profite également des
moments de faiblesse de la conscience
pour s'exprimer c'est ce que Freud
appelle les actes manqués les oublis de
nom propre de mots de langues étrangères
de noms communs et de suite de mots deux
mots liés à l'accomplissement d'un
projet de projet même de connaissance il
y a aussi les faux souvenirs les
souvenirs écrans qui masquent des
souvenirs refoulés les lapsus les
erreurs de lecture et d'écriture les
maladresses les erreurs et les accidents
enfin les rêves constituent le moyen
d'expression par excellence de
l'inconscient
qu'est-ce que le refoulement Freud
définit le refoulement comme une
conséquence naturelle de la division de
l'esprit entre la conscience et
l'inconscient c'est le mécanisme par
lequel des représentations liées à
certaines pulsions sont écartées du
champ de la conscience repousser ou
maintenu dans l'inconscient parce que
leur satisfaction est incompatible avec
d'autres exigences matérielles sociales
zumorales les pensées ou les souvenirs
refoulés sont en général de nature
sexuelle par exemple le garçon refoule
le désir sexuel qui l'éprouve pour sa
mère parce que la morale sociale
condamne ce désir
dans le détail le refoulement d'une
pulsion survient uniquement dans le cas
où le motif de déplaisir est supérieur
ou motif de plaisir concomitant la fin
par exemple est une pulsion qui ne peut
pas être refoulée elle doit forcément
être satisfaite en revanche le prétendu
désir sexuel du garçon pour sa mère s'il
s'exprime apportera plus de déplaisir le
déplaisir des sanctions sociales que de
plaisir c'est pourquoi il est refoulé
la satisfaction de la pulsion soumise au
refoulement ferait naître du plaisir à
tel endroit du déplaisir à tel autre
écrit Sigmund Freud dans le refoulement
enfin le refoulement est également un
processus mobile il n'est pas un
événement unique au succès durable il
s'agit au contraire d'un processus
permanent à l'effectivité précaire
conditionnée à un perpétuel
investissement d'énergie le refoulé
exerce une pression constante vers le
conscient duquel il subit en même temps
une pression contraire seul le sommeil
suspend le travail de refoulement de
nouveau actifs au réveil
l'objectif du psychanalyste est de faire
remonter le contenu inconscient à la
conscience ce qui est censé supprimer
les symptômes mais cela n'est pas facile
la censure intérieure du patient entrave
souvent le travail analytique parce que
Freud appelle la résistance
qu'est-ce que le complexe de DIP le
complexe de DIP est pour Freud la grande
découverte de la psychanalyse c'est le
désir de l'enfant pour le parent de
l'autre sexe et son hostilité pour celui
du même sexe ce concept est inspiré du
mythe de DIP
issu de la tragédie œdipe roi de
Sophocle le grand dramaturge grec du
cinquième siècle avant Jésus-Christ en
voici un résumé
œdipe et le fils du roi de Thèbes Laïos
et de Jocaste à sa naissance les oracles
prédisent qu'une fois adulte il tuera
son père et épousera sa mère il est donc
abandonné puis recueilli par une famille
si bien que personne pas même lui ne
sait qu'il est adulte il revient à
Thèbes il rencontre un vieillard qui est
son père combat ce vieillard et le tue
le trône désormais vide et la main de sa
mère lui seront donnés parce que deep
aura su répondre à la fameuse énigme du
Sphinx
c'est donc sans le savoir c'est à dire
inconsciemment que deep commet le
parricide et l'inceste cette situation
qui se réalise dans la légende serait
présente à l'état de désir dans tout âme
d'enfant le mythe serait révélateur de
l'évolution sexuelle du petit garçon
mais aussi de celle de la petite fille
appelée complexe d'Électre où les rôles
sont inversés
Freud a avoué que l'idée lui avait été
inspiré par son propre désir pour sa
mère qui était à la fois jeune et belle
tandis que son père avait 20 ans de plus
c'était son second mariage
Freud voulait vraiment tuer son père à
affirmer Sandor ferency un psychanalyste
hongrois qui a été le disciple préféré
de Freud
qu'est-ce que le malaise de la
civilisation
cette idée est celle que je trouve la
plus intéressante Freud écrit Malaise
dans la civilisation en un été à 73 ans
après la première guerre mondiale qui
invite à réfléchir au penchant à
l'autodestruction de l'humanité comme
beaucoup de savants spécialistes Freud
élargit sa perspective à la fin de sa
vie il applique donc ses idées à la
civilisation tout entière et pour se
faire il procède comme avec un patient
individuel il recherche dans le passé
c'est à dire qu'il s'intéresse aux
formes primitives de la société humaine
il imagine que les premiers hommes
vivaient en petite horde or déjà à cette
plus petite échelle de la vie collective
l'homme se rend compte que ses désirs
sont bornés par la résistance de ces
semblables conclusion de Freud toute vie
sociale même au degré le plus bas exige
une limitation
cette idée lui permet de répondre à la
question à laquelle Rousseau avait
répondu dans son Discours sur les
sciences et lézards pourquoi le
développement de la civilisation ne
rend-il pas l'homme plus heureux
pourquoi l'individu moderne éprouve-t-il
un malaise c'est-à-dire un
mécontentement chronique et bien réponds
Freud parce que l'enrichissement par la
culture ne lui a pas été donné
gratuitement il le paye par une
limitation inouïe de la liberté de ses
instincts autrement dit l'envers de tout
gain de civilisation pour l'espèce est
une perte de bonheur pour l'individu la
raison fondamentale est que la fonction
de la culture est de pousser l'individu
à faire passer l'intérêt collectif avant
son intérêt individuel
cependant le malaise n'est pas une
fatalité l'homme civilisé peut atteindre
le bonheur parce que Freud appelle la
sublimation la sublimation consiste à
détourner l'énergie des pulsions
dangereuses pour la société tout
particulièrement les pulsions sexuelles
vers d'autres buts dont l'homme attend
une assatisfaction esthétique
intellectuelle ou sociale ainsi plutôt
que de vivre dans la frustration l'homme
peut dépenser l'énergie de ses désirs
dans l'art dans la littérature dans la
politique etc
la sublimation est une des sources de la
production artistique a écrit Freud dans
ces trois essais sur la théorie sexuelle
quels sont les développements majeurs de
la psychanalyse je vais tout d'abord
vous parler du développement entreprise
indépendamment de Freud par Young le
deuxième psychanalyste le plus influent
dans la culture occidentale je vous
parlerai ensuite de la psychanalyse à la
cannienne qui a conquis la France dans
les années 1960 enfin je terminerai par
vous présenter trois autres
psychanalystes majeurs qui méritent une
place dans votre culture générale
comment young s'écarte-t-il de la
psychanalyse de Freud
Karl Gustave Young est un psychiatre
suisse plus jeune que Freud de 20 ans
intéressé par les mêmes questions il
s’écrit dans les années 1900 au début le
jeune young vous une admiration sans
borne à son aîné réciproquement en freux
de le tien en estime pour plusieurs
raisons Jung a été l'assistant de bloeur
Blu l e r un expert mondialement reconnu
en matière de psychiatrie Young a réussi
à assembler un groupe de freudiens d'un
bon niveau intellectuel et enfin Jung
n'est pas juif ce qui permettra que la
psychanalyse ne passe pas pour une secte
juive dans l'atmosphère antisémite de
l'époque
les deux hommes sont très proches par
exemple young se confie affreux de
lorsqu’il craint que sa relation avec
une patiente ne dégénère en scandale et
Freud de confie de plus en plus de
responsabilités à Young dans le
mouvement psychanalytique
seulement Jung se rend compte de la
fragilité de certaines conceptions
freudienne fondamentales il accuse son
maître de données une importance
disproportionnée à la sexualité il
rejoint par là tous ceux qui
reprochaient affreux de son
pansexualisme c'est-à-dire sa propension
à expliquer tout acte par une motivation
sexuelle voici ce qui est écrit young
dans son autobiographie ma vie mon
travail pratique m'avait fait connaître
de nombreux cas de névrose dans lesquels
la sexualité ne jouait qu'un rôle
secondaire
young doute également de la pertinence
du complexe de DIP à ses yeux ce n'est
pas le désir d'inceste qui est universel
mais l'évitement de l'inceste les mâles
sont programmés pour perpétuer l'espèce
avec de jeunes femmes fertiles et non
pour s'accoupler avec leur mère le
conflit intellectuel dégénère comme
c'est souvent le cas en conflit affectif
d'un côté freux de reproche à Young
d’adapter la théorie psychanalytique à
la morale sociale de l'autre Young qui
avait donné affreux de l'idée de
l'analyse didactique c'est-à-dire que
chaque psychanalyste se fasse
psychanalyser par un contraire Jung
reproche affreux de ne pas s'y mettre
lui-même
les deux hommes rompent l'année du
déclenchement de la Première Guerre
mondiale en 1914 young crée alors sa
propre version de la psychanalyse la
psychologie analytique son originalité
réside dans l'étude des relations entre
les dimensions individuelles et
collectives de l'esprit humain Jung
prend par exemple en compte l'influence
des mythes et des traditions dans le
façonnage des mentalités on appelle cela
la psychologie des profondeurs
voici les trois idées majeures de Young
première idée l'inconscient collectif
l'inconscient pour Young est composé de
deux couches la première superficielle
et l'inconscient personnel la seconde
plus profonde et innée est formée de
contenu que partage tous les individus
sans exception c'est un fondement
psychique universel super personnel
présente en chacun c'est l'inconscient
collectif
deuxième idée majeure de Young les
archétypes les hommes ont tendance à
utiliser à toutes les époques de
l'histoire et en tout lieu les mêmes
modèles élémentaires de comportement et
de représentation inscrit dans la
structure même du cerveau les archétypes
ce sont en pratique des images
archaïques et universelles rencontrés
avec une récurrence remarquable dans les
rêves les croyances religieuses limites
et les comptes troisième et dernier idée
majeure de Young la persona il existe
dans l'esprit humain une fonction
d'adaptation à la société en effet la
personnalité de l'individu s'adapte dans
son rapport à ses semblables pour
prendre l'apparence d'un personnage au
rôle social prédéfini une sorte de
masque la persona qui risque d'usurper à
la longue la véritable identité
j'ai développé ma présentation de Young
parce qu'il est après Freud le
psychanalyste qui a eu le plus
d'influence sur la culture occidentale
il doit en partie sa popularité au fait
qu'il s'est intéressé à des phénomènes
propres aux nouvelles spiritualité qui
ont émergé à la fin des 30 glorieuses en
Occident comme la connexion spirituelle
entre les êtres humains les
synchronicités et même les ovnis
comment l'aquant devient-il le nouveau
Freud Jacques Lacan est un psychiatre
français du XXème siècle surnommé le
Freud français il est la véritable star
française de la psychanalyse son
influence est si grande qu'à la fin des
trentes glorieuses la psychanalyse
française est intégralement la canyon
tant l'accord à former de disciples
comme je vous l'ai dit au début de la
leçon il a rendu encore plus facile
d'obtenir le titre de psychanalyste en
créant sa propre société de psychanalyse
l'histoire de la création de cette
société est révélatrice du personnage
depuis les années 1950 la Société
Française de Psychanalyse rappelle Lacan
à l'ordre afin qu'il respecte la règle
des 45 minutes lui vend des séances très
courtes la campe promet il s'énerve mais
il ne change rien en 1963 la Société
Française de Psychanalyse lui retire son
titre de didacticiel parce qu'on appelle
la directive de Stockholm il réagit donc
en créant sa propre société et en
libéralisant considérablement les règles
d'obtention du titre et les règles
d'exercices il a comme Freud une grande
influence chez les intellectuels il
inspire par exemple Altus r Badiou
Derrida valent et même des théologiens
catholiques il est classé parmi les
inspirateurs de Mai 68 bien qu'il ne
soit ni révolutionnaire ni même de
gauche
que retenir de l’œuvre de Lacan pour
faire simple il développe la théorie
psychanalytique en se concentrant sur
les effets du langage sur l'esprit
humain il distingue trois ordres dans le
rapport de l'homme au monde tout d'abord
l'ordre du réel soit l'objet en lui-même
même si l'esprit humain ne peut pas
atteindre l'essence de l'objet ensuite
l'ordre symbolique qui est le domaine
des images de langage associé à l'objet
et enfin l'ordre imaginaire qui
rassemble tous les fantasmes du sujet à
propos de l'objet
je ne développe pas davantage ma
présentation des idées de l'accord parce
que je crains qu'il ne soit un charlatan
en cela il ne nous permet pas de mieux
comprendre le monde c'est même plutôt le
contraire en effet son propos est une
obscurité inouïe au point que le
philosophe Jean-François révèle par
exemple considère que ce propos relève
de l'escroquerie verbale et l'accord
laissez délibérément planer le doute sur
le sens de son propos pour fasciner ses
auditeurs qui perdait ensuite leur temps
à essayer de comprendre mais écrit je ne
les ai pas écrit pour qu'on les
comprenne je les ai écrit pour qu'on les
lise a déclaré Jacques Lacan à propos de
ses écrits si Freud a défendu des idées
contestables il a pour sa part toujours
écrit avec le souci de se faire
comprendre il méprisait ce qu'il
appelait l'idolâtrie des mots
quels sont les autres psychanalystes
importants voici trois autres
psychanalystes qui méritent une place
dans votre culture générale le premier
c'est Alfred Adler c'est un médecin
autrichien de 15 ans plus jeune que
Freud comme young il est d'abord un
fidèle du fondateur de la psychanalyse
avant de rompre à cause de désaccords
théoriques virés de l'association de
Freud il crée alors sa propre école de
psychanalyse la psychologie individuelle
ainsi que sa propre association qui
l'appelle la société pour la libre
recherche psychanalytique sur le plan
des idées Adler admirateur de Nietzsche
explique tout par la volonté de
puissance chaque individu éprouve dès
l'enfance un sentiment d'infériorité et
ses forces dès lors de le surmonter en
recherchant la puissance
deuxième psychanalyste important
Eric from est un sociologue et
psychanalyste américain d'origine
allemande du XXe siècle il est un des
représentants majeurs du freudo marxisme
qui comme le nom l'indique consiste à
combiner le marxisme et le freudisme ce
mélange conduit from à remettre en cause
les idées de Freud qui ne prennent pas
en compte l'effet de la culture sur le
développement psychologique dans sa
perspective la culture et les conditions
d'existence présentes ont le rôle
respectivement de la sexualité et du
passé dans la perspective de Freud
l'objectif qu'il donne à sa théorie et
de libérer l'homme de l'importance qu'a
pris à la consommation dans son esprit
troisième et dernier psychanalyste
important Françoise Dolto est une
pédiatre et psychanalyste parisienne du
20e siècle elle représente la
concrétisation de l'ambition qui a eu
Freud à la fin de sa vie de faire de la
psychanalyse une formation à la
pédagogie de fait la France et le pays
où la psychanalyse a le plus imprégné la
pédagogie grâce au succès de Françoise
Dolto dans les années 1970 elle devient
très populaire grâce à une émission de
radio où elle répond psychanalytiquement
à des lettres de parents sur le fond ces
idées les plus influentes reviennent à
la nécessité de libéraliser l'éducation
il ne faut pas dévaloriser l'enfant
comme un individu de moindre valeur par
rapport à un adulte il faut lui dire la
vérité et Dolto légitime la crise
d'adolescence comme une étape de
vulnérabilité nécessaire en parlant du
complexe du homard l'adolescent est
psychologiquement vulnérable parce qu'il
est en train de changer de carapace
quelles sont les limites de la
psychanalyse la psychanalyse s'est
attirée beaucoup de critiques dès ses
origines elle lui reproche d'usurper le
statut de science d'être motivé par
l'engissement plutôt que par la quête de
la vérité et enfin de fonctionner comme
une secte je vais examiner ces trois
reproches un par un et vous résumez les
débats qui les entourent
la psychanalyse est-elle une science la
défiance des milieux scientifiques
envers la psychanalyse existe depuis son
apparition à la fin du 19e siècle pour
certains Freud était en réalité un
philosophe voit un charlatan Einstein
par exemple avec lequel Freud échange
des lettres dans les années 1930
Einstein ne croit pas aux théories
psychanalytiques si son fondateur voyait
la psychanalyse comme une science
naturelle les lacaniens eux rejetteront
cette idée le débat est relancé au début
du 21e siècle en raison de la
concurrence des thérapies dites
cognitivo-comportementales TCC thérapie
qui traite les troubles par des
exercices pratiques centrés sur le
comportement et les processus mentaux ce
qui est une approche bien plus concrète
et pragmatique que celle de la
psychanalyse une partie des
psychanalystes essaie de se conformer
aux critères de la science moderne en se
pliant aux exigences de la médecine par
l’épreuve EV Eden bays médecine en
anglais les preuves est en fournie par
des études cliniques systématiques
je vous résume le débat sur la
scientificité de la psychanalyse voici
les trois principaux arguments pour la
scientificité de la psychanalyse tout
d'abord elle est empirique et objective
en effet ces théories sont construites à
partir de faits issues de l'observation
clinique lorsque Freud présente ses
idées il précise qu'elle lui ont été
inspirés par un grand nombre de cas on
peut toutefois déjà objecter qu'il y a
un billet d'échantillonnage les passions
ne sont pas représentatifs de l'humanité
car ce sont tous des personnes à la fois
troublées et financièrement aisées
deuxième argument pour la scientifique
de la psychanalyse il y a une relative
unitée autour des théories de Freud ces
théories constituent donc pour parler
comme thomascune un paradigme
c'est-à-dire un cadre de travail accepté
par tous les acteurs de la discipline
cet argument est en réalité fragile car
comme on l'a vu les grands concepts
freudiens ont été contestés dès le
départ
troisième et dernier argument en faveur
de la scientificité de la psychanalyse
la théorie psychanalytique se corrige en
permanence l'observation clinique ne
cesse de questionner et de réfuter la
théorie ce qui garantit l'amélioration
progressive de l'adéquation entre la
théorie et la réalité il est vrai que
les difice théorique de Freud a évolué
jusqu'à sa mort cependant cette
évolution est problématique dans la
mesure où Freud ajoute de nouvelles
idées bien plus qu'il n'enlève ce qui
aboutit à complexifier l'édifice
théorique de grands concepts douteux
comme le complexe de DIP non pas été
abandonnés
voici maintenant les trois principaux
arguments contre la scientificité de la
psychanalyse tout d'abord elle manque de
rigueur c'est déjà le cas au niveau des
concepts fondamentaux qui ne sont pas
définis précisément junger raconte par
exemple qu'il avait demandé à Freud une
définition précise du concept de libido
et qu'il n'avait jamais obtenu la
réponse le manque de rigueur transparer
encore au niveau de l'enregistrement des
faits observées qui sont parfois
confondus avec des interprétations et au
niveau des interprétations de l'analyste
qui sont en partie aléatoire et qui en
se la relève bien davantage de l'art que
de la science comme le dit Stephen five
dans sa biographie de Freud nombre de
psychanalystes sont certes
d'impressionnants érudits mais
l'érudition et la science sont deux
choses différentes
deuxième argument contre la
scientificité de la psychanalyse elle se
protège contre la réfutation le
philosophe Carl Popper qui
s'enthousiasmer pour la psychanalyse
dans les années 1910 c'est ensuite rendu
compte que la plus grande force
apparente de la psychanalyse sont ni
réfutabilité était en réalité sa plus
grande faiblesse de son point de vue le
problème réside précisément dans le
concept d'inconscient qui permet de dire
que les intentions véritables mais
dissimulées de l'individu sont toujours
conformes à la théorie voici ce qui
écrit Popper dans conjecture et
réfutation ce qui refusaient la théorie
refusaient de voir l'évidence vérité à
cause de refoulement non encore analysé
et réclamant de façon criante une
thérapie
troisième et dernier argument contre la
scientificité de la psychanalyse elle
est fondée sur des mensonges je vous ai
déjà donné quelques exemples avec les
5ks classiques de la psychanalyse
freudienne pour l'historien néerlandais
Anne Israël
Hanni
pour cette histoire néerlandais Freud
était si confiant dans ses premières
théories qu'il s'était publiquement
Vendée de succès thérapeutiques qu'il
n'avait en réalité pas encore obtenu et
quand les résultats n'ont pas été au
rendez-vous il a été contraint de mentir
j'ai une hypothèse personnelle plus
précise sur cette question Freud ne
pouvait pas être humble et prudent comme
un scientifique parce qu'il consommait
trop de cocaïne
la psychanalyse est-elle un business les
critiques de la psychanalyse lui
reprochent souvent sa dimension
mercantile elle serait un juteux
commerce ce que les bénéficiaires
essaient à la fois de dissimuler et de
protéger le prix des séances apparaît
d'autant plus élevé de nos jours que
celui des thérapies cognitivaux
comportementales TTC est inférieur ça
s'arrête tout seul quand le malade n'a
plus d'argent elle dit un psychanalyste
à propos de la fin du traitement
il est vrai que l'argent était une
dimension importante du développement du
mouvement psychanalytique cela
s'explique probablement par l'histoire
personnelle de Freud il a longtemps été
impécunieux pendant ses études il
faisait très attention à ses dépenses et
il a repoussé son mariage pendant
plusieurs années par manque de moyens
jeune adulte il a encore emprunté de
l'argent auprès de ses connaissances il
paraît donc naturel qu'il est profité du
succès de ses idées pour se libérer des
soucis financiers qui lui ont en pesé
lorsqu'il peut enfin fixer ses propres
tarifs il s'en réjouit ces tarifs
augmenteront avec sa notoriété jusqu'à
atteindre paraît-il 450 euros de l'heure
enfin Freud fera de la psychanalyse une
entreprise familiale avec sa fille Anna
comme héritière légale des archives et
de l'oeuvre et son fils
Ernst à la tête de la maison d'édition
c'est Jacques Lacan qui représente la
dérive mercantile de la psychanalyse la
solution qu'il a trouvée pour décupler
son chiffre d'affaires n'est pas
d'augmenter les tarifs mais de réduire
la durée de la séance c'est l'origine de
son conflit avec la société française de
psychanalyse en instituant la technique
des séances à durée variable appliquées
spécialement dans les didactiques Lacan
analyse didactiquement plusieurs
dizaines de postulants par jour au fil
des années les séances deviennent de
plus en plus courtes parfois minuscules
comme un monarque laquant interrompt ses
sujets selon son bon plaisir et les
renvoie à la séance suivante parfois le
même jour quelques heures plus tard le
psychanalyste Gérard Haddad HA2 dad ce
psychanalyste raconte que Lacan lui
disait parfois à demain avant même qu'il
ne commence à parler la célébrité de
Lacan lui assure une clientèle
pléthorique et de riches parisiens
dépense des sommes folles chez lui
j'ai réussi en somme ce que dans le
champ du commerce ordinaire on voudrait
pouvoir réaliser aussi aisément avec de
l'offre j'ai créé la demande à déclarer
Jacques Lacan en 1958
Freud et Lacan se sont certes enrichis
grâce à leur pratique mais il serait
malhonnête de disqualifier la
psychanalyse à partir de leur seul
exemple on peut relativiser la dimension
mercantile de la psychanalyse en premier
lieu c'est le marché qui détermine les
tarifs de la psychanalyse les
psychanalystes les plus prestigieux sont
comme les médecins les plus prestigieux
les plus chers mais la grande majorité
des psychanalystes proposent des tarifs
abordables pour la classe moyenne en
cherchant sur internet on trouve des
psychanalystes à moins de 50 euros de
l'heure même à Paris en second lieu
certains grands noms de la psychanalyse
ont essayé de la sortir des classes
aisées par exemple Alfred hadler dont je
vous ai déjà parlé Alfred hadler surtout
des patients des classes moyennes et
inférieures et leur préoccupations
étaient d'ailleurs bien différente de
celle des patients de Freud elles
étaient davantage liées à l'existence
matérielle ou à la progression dans la
hiérarchie sociale plutôt qu'à l'amour
la psychanalyse est-elle une secte le
philosophe Ludwig vidgenstein qui vivait
comme Freud à Vienne ce philosophe
explique le succès de la psychanalyse
par le charme du sujet et par le charme
personnel de Freud certains vont plus
loin en comparant la psychanalyse à une
secte le charme personnel de freux de
fascine en effet ses disciples au point
qu'il fait penser au charisme d'un
gourou ses connaissances parlent
notamment de la puissance de son regard
qui donnait l'impression de pénétrer
jusqu'à l'âme de l'interlocuteur une
partie de ces patients s'attache à lui
il n'est pas rare que des patientes
tombent amoureuses de lui ce qui lui
inspirera le concept du transfert qui
signifie que l'analyser transfère
l'amour pour les parents sur l'analyse
ensuite l'histoire de Freud c'est
prétendu succès thérapeutiques et ces
théories constituent des mythes
fondateurs qui ne sont pas remises en
cause par les psychanalystes au
contraire il les protège contre les
suspicions des observateurs extérieurs
enfin frais d'organiser et souder le
mouvement psychanalytique un peu comme
un mouvement religieux il en protégeait
l'unité idéologique il passait beaucoup
de temps avec ses plus proches disciples
et leur disait que leur groupe devait
rester réunis contre l'hostilité du
monde extérieur il récompensait les plus
fidèles en leur confiant des
responsabilités et il excommunier comme
on l'a vu ce qui n'adhérait plus à ses
théories
ces arguments valent également pour la
psychanalyse et la canné Lacan exerçait
un grand ascendant psychologique sur ces
partisans ceci perdait tellement de
temps à essayer de comprendre son
discours qu'il ne pensait pas à le
remettre en cause et enfin l'accord a
créé sa propre association de gens
soudés autour des mêmes croyances après
on peut relativiser la dimension
sectaire de la psychanalyse pour
commencer Freud n'était pas un
manipulateur mais un brillant
intellectuel et un écrivain doué sa
domination n'a pas pu empêcher la
rupture avec ses disciples les plus
brillants qui n'étaient donc pas des
suiveurs sans esprit critique ni la
dispersion de la psychanalyse en
diverses écoles enfin le fait qu'elle se
revendique comme une science et qu'elle
adhère à l'idéal de la science empêche
qu'elle sombre dans l'irrationalité
d'une secte
alors la vidéo vous a plu j'espère que
oui je vous rappelle que c'est un
extrait de ma formation culture générale
culture Express si vous voulez en savoir
plus cliquez sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de les
vidéos ou bien sur celui qui est dans la
description de cette vidéo voilà voilà
comme d'habitude n'hésitez pas à
m'écrire dans les commentaires et puis
surtout n'oubliez pas que vous n'avez
pas besoin de vous prendre la tête pour
vous cultiver